they exit the chamber now assembly point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the city street please do not
delay your evacuation to protect any
Millions please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council Stella please note that this
meeting for people
and can I please remind you to switch
off them they both end or turn my style
we please be upstanding to receive the
Chairman's of Chapman an event indirect
good evening cancellous
welcome to next
and we remain standing for prayer
thank you good evening everyone
oh just very briefly as it's my final
appearance before you to talk about the
leadership you are all in some capacity
leaders representing people in a whole
host of different ways in the book of
Titus in the New Testament it says this
you yourself must be an example to them
by doing good works of every kind then
everything you do reflect the integrity
and seriousness of who you are
teach the truth so that the teaching
can't be criticized across the Bible in
the Old Testament and the New Testament
we discover that leaders should be
trustworthy leaders look out for other
people's interests and one of the
responsibilities is councils
and countenance is to do just that
leaders should represent God in one
respect or another you may agree or
disagree with that leaders should
receive advice but also be willing to
give advice leaders must serve others
but they should sacrifice themselves for
the good of the populace
so
by lasting mum here is to thank you you
are representatives of the community
that you served and on those who
well ago become once more into this
chamber as representatives of the
community that we have been voted in
while
we ask why or grace each and every
person here representing will honor
those who have elected them and
ultimately
be with the decision-making processes
be with each and every one so that they
may be people of integrity and all that
may your presence be felt in this
chamber on an ongoing basis name of
Jesus Christ and pray
- eh yeah so pointy [ __ ] thank you very
much
it's seated
- one that the agenda tonight
to elect a chairman and County 2018
we have any lemonade donations
nomination this year my pleasure through
my group to nominate question as
councillor
we separated years
very case you know thank you so who is
not scared
are there any other nominations safe
that agreed
I think having a decision
on the district
today I take that and we duty and
faithfully fulfill duty to the best of
my judgment
today to observe the code has to come
down
which is expected and it's
I think
my group to select a Virginia finish
who I fart on today
I smell new gender
you have to chew
Hey
you went if you won't believe how long
I've waited for this
Thank You chin up by yourself today but
can I just say
as as service extremely well this year I
think she's been extremely good in there
newspapers served as well I think as a
chairman you want to see a bit of life
you see life that's a good easy to war
in its case and I think you learn as a
chairman
I do hope you've got as well
who you had some of this as much charity
yes to try you will see some
and I think you come away from it
I think wiser and I think a little bit
more tempered
but cancer has been fantastic in
I really look forward to next year's
with so thank you very much room with me
back for us
other than phones
and I conservation Thomas myself having
Jeff could you move your what there's a
place okay
it will be very difficult follow that
chair and such as lazy butcher having
witnessed firsthand the mandate which is
discharge of duties Chairman's prepared
my standard which this council can be
just and fair and has promoted the
dispute remember the opportunity has
presented itself and I have had the
pleasure honor and advantage of
accompanying that to many of the
functions she has attended which I have
learnt the earth will enhance my ability
to represent the district to the highest
standard certainly that is my intention
thank you now we need to refer back to
the vice-chairman so that he may take
the Declaration acutely Thank You
chairman I thought we Richard drank have
you been elected to the office of vice
chairman of the Council of the District
of Roger declare that I take that office
upon myself and will Julian's faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability I
undertake to observe the code as to the
conduct which is expected of members or
the Rochford of District Council
I'll refer back to the agenda problem
and we're up to item 5 the chairman of
the Council appoints Jackson and I will
do so today today five six to receive
apologies perhaps miss we have one
apology in the office councillor SP are
there any other apologies thank you very
much I some seven minutes of the meeting
held on the 24th April 2008 een on the
ministry's very very new light and eight
announcements from the Chairman and or
pay page service there are none right
and denying district encounter parish
council election results there's no
teeth members nasty nose area thank you
thousand ten Baker's a group membership
[Applause]
pointman
executive committees and subcommittees
put you 18 and 19
there we have specific specific
recommendations for it made IQs and it
was heavy for me to take those again
Thank You chairman firstly the leader
the council's executive portfolios and
associated appointees I've set out to
the vendors through on page eleven point
two of the documentation and that's
which houses in those chair got another
microphone or somebody I'm not sure with
children I just like that this point to
say thank you to all those members of
the executive that serve discounts are
extremely well last year and in
particular counselors fairy who decided
to go back if you like one foot back
this year to the coffee family and do
other things and I think he served us
very well for the last two years I think
recycling systems are established the
new great game a green gateway and not
many other things that we've done is
actually had made a precedent for this
council I would like to thank him for
what he's done
so we just threw you chair like that
energy thank you
like a German secondly the political
composition of the council should be
reflected in the allocation of seats on
the council's committees and
subcommittees the appendix attached to
the report that's page 11.5 11.6 show
seat allocations based on the current
composition in accordance to the fun
part of these councils us to exhaust
appendage any German group leaders at be
invited to nominate the council's
committees and the security item 11
addendum 1 commencing on page eleven
point seven sets out the membership of
committees and the subcommittee as
though you'll be taking on board the
nominations received could council
endorsed at this chairman
finally nominations have been received
from group leaders to the appointment of
Chairman and vice chairman of committees
and and the subcommittee these are set
out on pages II live 11.10 and 11.11 or
addendum to revised that's the document
has been table this evening members and
can be endorsed subject to council
dealing with the two nominations the
Chairman and vice chairman of the
licensing committee two nominations for
chairman of the review committee and two
nominations for vice chairman of the
standards committee
chairman those nominations are
determined by by way of show of hands so
for the chairman of the licensing
committee could there please be a show
of hands the council
from now Picasso's Indonesia
so that is constantly the voice chairman
of the licensing committee could there
be a show has the council Hazelwood
thank you now for counselor okay thank
you so that's counselor Hazelwood the
chairman of the review committee could
that please be a show of hands the
counselor burden
[Music]
you know forecastle hook wait please
and finally chairman
so that's counselor but fine be chairman
for vice-chairman of the standards
committee could the previous owners
I'm never counselor FD please
thank you that's custard right I mean
that concludes their life the business
thank you
- 12 degrees see the dedication sit out
in 3a and see the Constitution improve
the scheduling of meetings of the
council July 2018 30 October 2018
2018-2019 9 February 20 19 and 30 day
for 2019 static weekend item item 42
outside toys and other forms for the OGS
19 Thank You general counsel is required
to make the decisions set out at pages
14 point three fourteen point four
report
the first recommendation is the
appointment of officer important
oversight bodies
for this minute year and the basis set
out appendix one at the report and it's
one that's on page fourteen point five
at least vhm that a good memory really
you know secondly remember
representatives including substitutes
being appointed for this municipal year
to the outside knowledge set out at
appendix two of the reports the main
bodies and nominations received are set
out on pages fourteen point nine and
fourteen point ten of addendum one
so that's right and fourteen addendum
one for one of these bodies the Essex
flood partnership or two nominations
have been received or one appointment
please for counsel at the view on it
before we go there gasps mr. white wants
to speak to the throwbacks
thank you in that case if we can have a
show of hands and push the Platte County
water
only a six foot partnership
I'm never counselor Stephanie
so that's counselor you want to tell me
to recommendation 3 I'll speak from
there it's some justification sort of
the parabolic which relates to 193
correspondence written we've and over
the last year previously mr. boss know
about this that there are that we don't
know all of the partnerships and awfully
grateful if these would be published
either in the public documents like this
I'll just let plenty to all vendors the
specific lot of network which is
produced the types of community teams
for instance which I believe council is
representative on into the AGM minutes
anyway and to the I attended last year
so it really is that that's a request
that we could have to perform at least
available to us all of these external
part ships that's possible
she's got some so she decides its are
doing so true if counsel soso decides
that that should be done then yes there
can be done and once we pretty much
antenna counseling advice suited for the
motion for you are yes I am good
introduction is you handsome thank you
yes you have a second yeah go fetch it
so can we take a boat on there those all
those in favor
Thank You chairman I am going to refer
back to item 14 addendum one please
the Essex flood partnership these
substitutes on that body there's one
appointment we have two nominees
counselors Williams and Stanley sofa
substitutes upon the Essex split
partnership board because we have a show
of hands please
the counselor Williams
another counselor Stanley face
so that's council Williams Chen
recommendation for appointments to the
three seats on the sanctuary and
Rocksmith committee which the
nominations are set out in the first
table on page 14 points 11 of addendum 1
and that's for agreeing to
recommendation 5 the appointment to the
portfolio holder for community to the
Essex police and crime panel and the
nomination for progress and substitute
the poor target holder for community
nominated Chancellor mrs. McPherson to
attend at the Essex police and crime
panel on their behalf they've also
nominated counselor mrs. Gooding to
attend the South End University Hospital
Board of Governors aspect out of context
14.2 sorry 14.12 evidently to
recommendation 6
Oh
chairman that will come under
recommendation sentence which we will
get into in a short while the
recommendation that the community to the
Essex County wide travel unit and the
nomination
you finally check the pockets the four
seats on the local highways panel the
nominees are set out in the lower table
on the page 14 2011 of addendum 1 that's
item 14 addendum 1 in accordance with
previous arrangements the appointee
would be the portfolio holder councillor
Ward and three other members there are
four nominees for these three
appointments chairman could the please
be a show of hands for councillor
Hazelwood
please be show of hands the council a
warning now if it the please be show
hands forecaster mister
and now could the police be a show of
hands to Castro canal
gems of appointees of councillors
Hazelwood you all knew and wishes row
and that concludes this item business
[Music]
please be understanding there's a chance